hello oh hello may I speak with William
Nordhaus please my name is Adam Smith
I'm calling from nobelprize.org which is
the website of the Nobel Prize in
Stockholm yeah good morning good morning
well congratulations on the award of the
Prize in Economic Sciences thank you how
did the news actually reach you the news
reached me when one of my children
called actually a few minutes ago we
were sleeping and and we woke up phones
ring and talked to my daughter what a
lovely way for the news to come it's a
striking coincidence that the news of
your prize comes on the same day that
we're hearing about the IPCC special
report highlighting the enormous
transformations that are going to be
needed if we're going to keep within
reasonable temperature rises you called
on almost any day there will be a story
somewhere in the newspaper and the
science journals in economic journals
about climate change and its causes and
its impacts and that's the sign of the
duplicitous nature so I know this is a
report it's a useful report and it's
it's collecting together what we've been
studying and learning over the last
actually 30 or 40 years and it's an
important reminder of the dangers we
face and the things that need to be done
and does your work make you hopeful that
we can do what needs to be done
I'd say my most recent work has made me
somewhat concerned about the fact that
we're doing so little the the most
recent work I've done is studying actual
trends in abatement and in policies
suggest we're doing much less than needs
to be to reach any of their targets
whether it's a 1 and a half to B or two
degree or even that's basically target I
think the policies are lagging very very
miles miles miles behind the science and
the need to what need to be the one
needs to be done hmm so it's hard to be
optimistic and also where we've fallen
behind because of the policies we're
actually going backwards in the United
States with the disastrous policies of
the Trump administration hmm I'd say it
and enemies that were personally and I
always use the word realism that dark
realism today yeah and it's not just the
United States that may be pulling out of
these Accords other than on the horizon
yeah they're having different places are
doing different things but it's not too
late but the steps we have to take more
difficult now than if we'd started
earlier hmm would you highlight one
thing as being the single most important
thing for people to do well the first
thing is that people have to come to
grips with difficulties we face
I think the scientists haven't and many
of the people have but the government's
have to and then the second thing was
most important so we take some kind of
economic steps I have advocated for many
years for carbon tax as a way of
implementing policies and then the third
thing is we'll have to have a
significant technological transformation
of course those first two would help the
third but those three has to go together
you can't do without public support but
you can't do it without some kind of
economic signals in the form of a carbon
tax and then all of those will help
induce the technological changes that
are necessary to make a transition to a
low-carbon world and all that is
difficult enough to achieve if you
believe that this is what needs to be
done but if you don't believe goodness
where do you start well the first thing
you can't do it without looking without
the public awareness I think I think I
should we have a fair amount of progress
on public awareness if you look at what
the surveys suggest and what people say
yeah
it's actually the NGO the government's
are lagging behind the people here yeah
I do want to just ask what was your
daughter's reaction when she told you
the news oh this is very sweet very
sweet I think it probably goes down as
one of the best we very much look
forward to welcoming you to Stockholm in
December so okay thank you very much
thank you once again congratulations
thank you